how's it going bros my name is pewdiepie
and welcome to
[Music]
i forgot i can't believe it i forgot to
record the y last week i'm sorry
i'm not worthy let's check out me uh
teacher for the boys i don't want any
long hair in this class it looks so
unprofessional the pictures on top of
the black boat
i like keanu reeses
i know it's me as well but come on come
on is that abraham lincoln
who's that who's that man that gabe
newell he's got long hair now have you
seen him this is the gabe i remember
right
he looks like christmas for video games
i like it but can your chair do this
hell yeah oh
japanese okay all right it's 3d whatever
yes
i want a real hand though i want like a
a monthly subscription servant not
the other s word
of course why am i making this joke i
just want someone to wipe my ass is that
so much to ask hello
that's cool oh it didn't even slides in
ooh
i guess i'm just
this is awesome austin bradley one of
the greatest supporters of the channel
he now have an etsy so every all the
stuff that he's made uh for the channel
you can actually buy and the price is so
cheap look he's got expendable katana
sick
so
okay so you get a paint teddy i figured
it was like dude are you making any
money with these prices if you have to
paint them like look at the details
that's so cool he's been selling mini
bernie sanders
that's so cool check out austin bradley
3d on etsy i'll leave a link in the
description pewdiepie was the one to
inspire me to make youtube videos and
today i hit a hundred thousand
subscribers oh sick
all right
and his name is felix just like me
[Music]
dude i'm too tired for this i can't do
it i got like brain fog today please
spare me did you have to do it i was
hoping for something wholesome
i mean g fuel man
average doomsday fan
i'm surprised the lack of uh doomsday
memes but here we go a rich sleeping
joke
[Laughter]
hey i wanted to do more videos like that
with that girl we'll see it did terribly
but it's the stuff i enjoy like rating
dumbest death in history did super well
i'm so glad because i had such a blast
recording that the stereotypes are not
real also
yes
no they're def
definitely real it's so funny when i
called her out on it too she's like i
don't do that mama me i don't do that
what are you saying
[Music]
[Applause]
they say mamma mia they say it
all the time it's not just something
and you know what they eat pizza and
pasta all the time
and
everything is true
yes i mean
i would love to record another video
with jack but i'm not sure if this is
the most fun thing we can
we could do as for norwegian i can
confirm it's 100 sure norwegians
anything stupid happening i bet the
swedish
no way
no way that's so rude you killed our
king okay you're the one with weak eyes
you apologize i found pewdiepie chair in
the dump
yeah yeah you know what that's a as a
fake pewdiepie chair no one would ever
throw away a really tightly and leather
pewdiepie chair come on can you do this
huh
you can
i mean i know he can do that but that's
i understand that he yeah all right
uh did you know blood donors in sweden
get a text message whenever their blood
saves someone's life the program hopes
to recruit and retain more donors by
highlighting their importance and
getting them excited about making a
difference cool i wish i did something
similar with charity because as an epic
charity donator thanks a lot to you guys
uh you don't always get updates on how
the money is spent and what it's done
and it would be nice just saying i
understand that's extra resources in
time but
also nice uh when listen
l
listen change skin
i didn't know that
why would they do that i don't like that
yo have you seen jeffrey bezos eating an
iguana i think about this photo all the
time close your eyes if you don't want
to see it he's eating mark zuckerberg
this photo was taken when facebook
value was increasing rapidly as a threat
for uh i can't believe that picture
exists it's so beautiful dudes it's been
seven years i'm still waiting for an
explanation
next meme feuds avoiding controversies
for the past two years to be like bro
how'd i do it though
kp from yubeli was here oh [ __ ] hell
it's kp what up dude
starting to know who you guys are now
that's weird
how we do it i think uh finally no one
cares anymore i can say what i want
right it's time
to return
i made pewdiepie lager using 3d software
that's cool it looks epic
imagine dying a slow horror i know where
this is going horrible death
in ancient rome just to be rated f tier
by a swedish man 6 000 years later
because he didn't think the way he died
was cool who did i write f here no i
always bump up the really bad bad ones
to eat here
as consolidation price i'm sure they'd
appreciate it i love some comments on
that video it was like this is so
insensitive like to who
too soon is it too soon the joke like
what
how many how many thousands of years do
you have to wait until you can
uh spoilers for the next episode um yeah
man drank mercury how's that my fault
huh
man drank bull blood i don't know
oh beautiful oh my [ __ ] god dude that
is gorgeous i gotta send that to ken
oh god
delete
i'll never be able to watch titanic
again you are known for vikings fjords
the country felix hates them
oh man i need to make a video like the
one i did for sweden but for norway i'm
curious i bet they don't even have
history there can they speak in norway
do they have anything hasburg after
keeping the bloodline pure but
having kids with each other beautiful
blow a beautiful any hey british people
be like no all right sorry sorry about
that british people pewdiepie does
nothing the vegan teacher incredible job
i know pescetarian gang just superior to
vegan gang sorry [ __ ] bees
[Music]
[Laughter]
he still comes to me
he's the one that snuggles up next to me
at night
that's pathetic beta [ __ ] oh my god i
don't know if this is interesting but to
me it was hilarious we went out for like
30 minutes and
then when we came back edgar hadn't
noticed that we had come back my dog
edgar pug show
i don't know where it
is and he was howling the most pathetic
noise i have ever heard it was so sad
that we were gone for 30 minutes you can
imagine
a wolf howling because they have the you
know big snap but a pug it just look it
looks so dumb it looks so pathetic it
was so cute
it was so silent too like
dumb people dying weird waves
japanese layer tears bruh i wish she
lived longer i wish diogenes laertes was
immortal so you could witness more
deaths because the medieval ages was
disappointing hmm
if you think this is funny don't don't
look at a euro coin that's the biggest
cuck norwegian has ever done to us
combined we're a penis but remove
remove norway and picture sweden and
finland you do you do the math me and
the boys seem to be similar hey
hey
oh yeah i gotta check this out me maker
hell yeah i forgot about that so we
added me maker in the greatest game of
all time tuber simulator and dispense
wisdom oh it's fun what's your wisdom
super simulator will forever be relevant
that is good wisdom nice
whoa
that's so cool you can do that
pewdiepie's first minecraft series in
tuberc
i love that beautiful
me casually gaming the dead body on my
floor yeah the game is weird
it may be irrelevant but it's
how do you think i got views
jesus christ
eat toilet paper and get clean on the
way out modern plural limbs require
modern solutions i don't get it okay
moving on take the title of the last
song you heard and add in my ass
hell yeah
hell yeah oh
eggy
so cute
egg is the cutest no maya is secured but
eggy also the cutest i challenge pewds
to appear the world yo is that austin
bradley well i guess i'll die decide if
pear falls on newton instead of an apple
i don't believe the apple story am i the
only one i should get an apple oh [ __ ]
now i get gravity no i don't believe it
and no one thought about this hey why i
jump i come back down huh no one's
thought about that before no one no one
you're telling me no one thought of this
did no one jump and be like why i calm
down i don't [ __ ] know oh apple fell
okay now i get it no dumb
yeah yeah this is where i really put my
heels in
this is the hill i'll die on newton's
i'm just kidding hey listen love a
birthday
oh rip ah no
no
boys we lost a legend today posted meme
reddit a bunch of random teenagers from
the subreddit and a 30 year old swedish
dude coming out to judge the size of my
peepee
it's this
stop
stop felix you had to go away
when you increase the media volume on
your phone and still can't hear the porn
video but then you see the bluetooth
symbol on the top
what is the context of this clip i mean
i know it says right there but still
oh bruh i remember coming home really
drunk one time i was like 18 and i came
back and i was still kind of
vibing you know as you do
i put on music in my headphones and
blasted i was like [ __ ] yeah this is
awesome
my dad just comes in and stares at me
with this such shame and disappointment
like going on we're like what the [ __ ]
are you doing and i was like
oh
i didn't plug it i didn't plug it
she fixed it you're welcome sniper wolf
finally the sofa arc has an end nice
and long one
did you order a new piece it doesn't
look right hey pewds so i got this inked
a few days ago i hate myself and and
talking about myself so i'll try to keep
it as short as possible i've been it's
been a while now since i first watched
pewdiepie and what i love the most is
how all of us grew with him oh this is
too much of sharing of emotions i don't
like this but here i go pierce i love
you man i will forever look at you as an
elder brother hell yeah i guess it's
safe to say that you're what is keeping
me going i feel like you're protecting
me with that oh brah
epic dude it looks good i like it epic
brofist i hit it
no one ever answered
where are you from
oh what
hey a mogus
nice beautiful i look extra swedish in
this i like it like father likes
[Laughter]
okay another epic week of friday
actually upload it on a friday what
that's awesome as always thanks for all
the support been really enjoying doing
videos that i just feel like instead of
worrying about what gets traction so i
appreciate that thank you guys and see
you next time until then
but true relevance never really died
welcome to the first undead game use any
item in your inventory and make memes
inside tuber simulator add some of our
patented stickers in there stickers our
emotions means our emotions
express your emotions with me
show them for likes share them for love
get up for free
and who knows
maybe i'll review your memes the
greatest honor of all time full circle
baby download it make a meme
we need subtitles on this